it was completely predictable that
republican senator ted cruz's approval
rating was going to fall
among uh democrats and among
left-leaning independents
after he in a completely i mean i i
don't know what he was thinking but he
well actually i do know what he was
thinking he fled with his family to
cancun
when the power went out in his home
state of texas and what he was thinking
was
quite clear which is i want to have
power let's go somewhere where it's warm
and there's power that's exactly what he
was thinking
until it completely blew up in his face
and so we were expecting that his
already low approval among democrats and
left-leaning independents
was going to fall but ted cruz's
approval rating
has collapsed 20 points among
republican voters and this is really a
signal of the worst situation for ted
cruz
since he took office in 2013 quite
frankly according to a yahoo yougov
poll uh 24 um percent of voters
approve of him overall and 49 disapprove
that's a
net approval of -25
for ted cruz but that's overall and when
you look at the
republican numbers in a morning consult
poll
ted cruz is at 53 approval among
republicans that's down 23 points
from january on january 9th
after the trump riots 76 percent of
republicans supported ted cruz
and that number is now down 23 points to
53 percent republican support for ted
cruz nearly
half of the republican party does not
approve of ted cruz and that is
absolutely
stunning ted cruz's approval was already
sort of on the decline in january
if you go back to december you see that
in the period
uh from december 27 to january 5
cruz's approval was 81 among republicans
then january 6 to 9 the immediate
aftermath of the riot he was down from
81 to 76
approval among republicans and then now
53
approval among republicans now for us
the unfortunate reality and it's been a
reality
that's much bigger than ted cruz for a
long time ted cruz isn't up for
re-election until 2024. he just won
in 2018 six-year terms for senators
up again in 2024 that's an insanely long
amount of time for this to have any
effect electorally
i know that we can hope that voters will
remember this in 2024
i think it's just too long the
circumstances
in 2024 for ted cruz are going to be
far more dictated by what's going on
at the time is trump the republican
nominee
or not uh other factors at that point
and if this were to have an effect it
would be getting ted cruz to resign
now there seems to be no chance that
that happens i've seen no indication
whatsoever no reason to think ted cruz
is going to resign
over this the way out of ted cruz
as a senator in texas is to register new
voters
and to get out the vote it's not to
convert existing republican voters
what we've learned many times is that if
you rely on republican voters
to remember the horrible things that
their elected officials did
you don't win it's just not a winning
strategy is what we've learned over time
ted cruz will have a bounce back he has
now
four years to start getting on all of
the tired tropes so we've got to fight
socialism and the debt is a little you
know all that stuff
he'll have a bounce back there will be
some
you know tragedy of some kind that will
allow him to talk about how the left
wants to take your guns
and if he wants to be re-elected he
almost certainly will
if we leave it to republicans
in texas to decide and remember the
things he did
the way to defeat ted cruz is to get out
the vote
and to register new voters and um if
this re-election campaign for cruz were
maybe in 2022
there'd be more of a shot at the cancun
fiasco having an impact if it were 2021
it would be even better
but the cautious optimism for 2024
is that cruz did only defeat beto
o'rourke by
a small margin about 51 to 48 in 2018.
if the election were now or in a few
months and we were hammering hammering
hammering on get out the vote and
registering voters
i think beto o'rourke would have a real
shot at defeating ted cruz
four years from now makes it more
difficult to predict
but let's prove ourselves wrong if ted
cruz is going to be defeated on 2024 it
will be because of the campaign that we
mount then
we saw the model in georgia with stacy
abrams and registering
new voters joe biden winning georgia
two democratic challengers uh in the
senate in georgia defeating two
republican incumbents in georgia
so it can be done we've seen the the
playbook
simply waiting for the cancun fiasco to
affect republicans
four years from now that's not the
winning strategy i'm open to having my
mind change but i've seen no evidence
that that's the way to
win that seat back let's face it most
healthy snacks don't taste
that good they don't fill you up they
don't really satisfy your cravings
which is why you should check out monk
pack today's sponsor
monk pack keto nut and seed bars taste
like your favorite delicious sweet
snacks but each bar
has less than one gram of sugar only two
to three grams of net carbs and they're
just 150 calories these are perfect
for a keto or low carb diet or
anybody who wants to cut back on sugar
flavors include caramel sea salt sea
salt dark chocolate
and peanut butter dark chocolate that's
my go-to i love
the monk pack keto nut and seed bars
because they're just a good balance of
sweet and salty
soft and chewy and a great crunch from
the nuts and seeds
and they will give you all of your money
back if you don't love them
as much as i do go to monkpack.com
the link is down below and they'll give
you 20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman